la meningitis viral es una infección que
ocurre principalmente en los niños
menores de 5 años sucede cuando ciertos
virus invaden los menínges que son
tejidos que cubren y protegen
el cerebro
y la médula espinal
los meninges se disponen en tres capas
la capa que realmente toca el cerebro y
la médula espinal se llama Pía madre
la capa media tipo tela de araña se
llama aracnoides
la capa más dura y exterior se llama
dura madre
el líquido cerebro espinal que además
protege el cerebro y la médula espinal
fluye entre los meninges y sobre la
superficie del cerebro
la causa más común de meningitis viral
es un tipo de virus llamado enterovirus
otros virus que causan meningitis pueden
incluir el virus de la papera
sarampión
el virus del herpes
y una variedad de virus que se esparcen
a través de la sangre
alimentando insectos tales como
mosquitos y garrapatas
los virus que causan meningitis pueden
transmitirse a través de la picadura de
un insecto infectado
sin embargo los dos modos más comunes de
la diseminación del virus es a través de
la contaminación fecal que puede suceder
cuando las manos no se lavan luego de
usar el baño o cuando se cambian los
pañales y a través de contacto con los
líquidos corporales de una persona
infectada tales como estornudos o tos
una vez dentro del cuerpo el virus se
reproduce
e ingresa en el torrente sanguíneo los
virus viajan por el torrente sanguíneo
hasta el cerebro donde cruzan el límite
entre el torrente sanguíneo y el cerebro
hasta el líquido cerebro espinal
los virus se diseminan por todo el
líquido cerebro espinal e infectan las
células de los meninges
los meninges se inflaman cuando el
sistema inmune comienza a pelear contra
la infección
los síntomas de la meningitis viral en
los bebés y en los niños pequeños
incluyen fiebre
irritabilidad
pérdida del apetito
y problemas para despertarse
los síntomas en adultos y niños más
grandes incluyen fiebre
dolor de cabeza tortícolis
sensibilidad a la luz
somnolencia
problemas para despertarse
náuseas
vómitos
y pérdida del apetito
los síntomas de la meningitis viral son
similares a los de la meningitis
bacterial pero son Generalmente menos
graves
los médicos pueden recomendar
acetaminofén u otro medicamento
antiinflamatorio no esteroideo para la
fiebre y el dolor de cabeza para la
meningitis causada por un tipo de virus
del herpes los médicos pueden recetar un
medicamento antiviral tal como Aciclovir
no hay tratamiento para la mayoría de
los virus que causan la meningitis sin
embargo la mayoría de las personas se
recuperan en un lapso de dos semanas